hmm that was amazing what is that I got
my brother in the next room coughing his
guts up because he's really ill and I'm
just hoping that I don't get it I've got
a very busy week but anyway hello how
are you I'm just waiting for some people
to turn up if you're watching this after
it's live cuz I'm gonna keep this up
basically what I am doing today is
playing through perfection as a
developer as the game designers so I'm
gonna talk to you about kind of where my
head was at how we came up with a few
decisions what our intentions where our
versus what actually became can you hear
me I don't know wait the game is right
up so you should be able to hear me I
don't know you guys are gonna tell me if
you can't hear me anyway I just pop you
here but yeah so that's what's gonna
happen right now I mean I was gonna wait
just for some people to come in because
I wanted you guys to like ask me things
live if you had questions I gotta say
one one major thing is thank you to
everyone who found and played perfection
on itch if you want to play it the link
is in the description below and I was
like blown away it was so weird because
I was actually on a social media break
because I very much needed one and yeah
I just I came back I had put the game up
on it during the social media break
because I'm like currently looking for
jobs and stuff so I let you just put it
up there to link to potential jobs
potential potential and yeah I came back
and I was like wait how has this got so
many downloads why is why is there links
to YouTube videos
why have I have so many notifications
have I have I can't even speak English
what is my life but yes so
just thank you thank you so much this
was honestly like crazy because it's
just a little student project that I I
just ironed out a little bit after
University and I hoped that it might
help me find a job but turns out it's
also found you guys and you've gotten
some enjoyment out of it and you enjoy
the concept which you don't understand
how happy I am that you enjoy the
concept like thank you so much because
that concept was my baby for the longest
time I could tell you the whole story of
where the concept came from and I guess
I probably will but yeah well we'll wait
until we start playing the game let's
say hi to who is here so hey gamer bf2
1:42 hey Yaga muffin haven't seen you in
a while hello Yaga muffin and tabs tabs
in the chance so Tabitha I know if you
watch this after it's live is why you
can see the chat which it's really good
thank you for doing that you do so
Tabitha is the character modeler so if
you have any character model questions
she's your gal she's the one to ask hey
Michael hey wanderson Rodriguez that's a
lovely name so yeah how about we just
get into it and then I guess I just
talked you through I was thinking this
could be like you know like how when you
watch films and then it's just literally
the game director or something just
commenting over the tops like oh yes we
chose this shot because of this but blah
blah so that's what I was thinking so
oh yeah I have to change oh yes one sec
and I should probably put desktop all
your dances might be loud
Boop there we go
let me pop out the chat as well while
I'm here hey Jacob oh para hello hello
hello thank you for coming
just so I get a gauge as well how many
of you guys in the chat have actually
played the game obviously taps I knew
you have users like I have played the
game let me know if you can still hear
me over the game audio hopefully you can
I'm gonna try and stay close to my
microphone I might you put it on the
other side whoo moving you guys because
I keep looking over at the chat so it
just makes sense to put the microphone
here okay
[Music]
so I yes I'm just so used to this I had
this so so much if you like the music
my grandpa was in Vietnam and Korean
ironically he died from flipping a
tractor on himself
what IPF really is that is what okay I'm
getting distracted I'm confused
Who I am hi amigos hi who I am and hi
Gabriel hi Carol
white like let me write I will carry on
like sorry once I quite so the audio is
amazing it's not it should loop now
thank you
yeah the your audio is amazing the sound
design is amazing I worked with Jamie
her Jamie horizon Jamie at horizon
productions the guys thought Jamie that
the production studios caught Jamie
Jamie no it's not called horizon
productions
oh my god I put all this info in the in
the description after I've uploaded this
but I'll put it in the chat quickly now
actually so I keep going off the games
the the music keeps dropping out but
yeah he's he's such a good sound
producer we're also working together on
my EP that's gonna come out in December
if all goes well because it's finished
now I just need to do the art for it but
yes so I've just put up his Twitter
account he's great I basically just sent
him the storyboards the one sheet like
everything that we had for the game that
explained what it was what the narrative
was what the mood was and then we kind
of talked about the cues the way where I
needed music for and he also did the
voice the voice overs so the man's voice
that you hear in the beginning video and
in the very beginning of the game that's
all him and I wanted to kind of be like
you know how in Portal you have this
false sense of security because you've
got like the companion Cuban stuff I
wanted him to be like that so at the
beginning of the game you feel like you
have a friend and I wish we had more
time for him to actually interact with
you more
and kind of make little jokes at you and
stuff like that because we've got we've
got stuff in we're in the beginning of
the game if you look at the security
cameras like smile your own camera and
that's supposed to kind of represent
like if you're being vain and you're
like oh look it's me because I do that
when I'm in shops anyway
let's actually play this Jamie is so
committed to production that he'd
changed his last name right oh my gosh
why can't I speak yes Jamie at Horizon
productions and I've just put history
account in so let's play this I want to
make sure you can see everything yep you
can see if they're okay so I wanna see
this
the menu scream it's a bit naff not
gonna lie I didn't spend very long on
this and they should probably put more
time on this on this in this we so out
of a team in our university let me know
if you can't hear me by the way in our
university we were kind of told that you
were supposed to have a character artist
an environment artist a game designer a
GUI artist anything else
[Music]
oh and I guess oh and a concept artist
as well so that's like six people wait
environment character game designer
Curie concept five people so at least to
meet like a short little 10-minute indie
game and we were three so we didn't have
a GUI artist we didn't have a concept
artist and we had to share that role so
this screen the menu screen would have
been created by the GUI artist but
because we didn't have one I did I was
kind of like and they'd already made the
spiral so I just figured okay just put
an image here make it super big make it
like spiral look at the kaleidoscope and
then I was playing on the particle
effects because this isn't actually 2d
this is in a 3d space made in unity and
I saw that you could like put little
lines in between the particles and I was
like damn that cool because it kind of
reminded me of a technology of yeah of
tech and
[Music]
yeah I just thought I'd be like like
call her or you know like DNA strands
and stuff but it's all like web I don't
I don't know and then I showed Tabitha
who's in the chat and Tiffany who's the
environment artist and they liked it so
that's basically how this came about and
then I've got like controls and
everything's glitzy when you press it
because the whole premise of this is
that you put on the headset and it
basically glitches out your head so
anyway let's let's actually blame
[Music]
so now I did make this video and I was
extremely proud of this video but it's
annoying because I've watched it so many
times now and I'm sure you guys have oh
yeah I can skip it you I'm gonna skip it
it was literally me in my bedroom not at
night this voice is Jamie so I sent in
the scripts and he did all this audio
[Music]
and I added to dit in Premiere Pro and
After Effects or did send him me singing
it so that he could put that in okay so
this is just this is actually a loading
screen so the game is like loading now
and it takes bloody forever I have so
much to do in in the sense of like
making it run better but it's much
better than it used to be trust me I
know it's stupid but it's so much better
than he used to be so this is the little
animation I did it took me like two days
and it takes a long time it was like
keyframe by keyframe putting the camera
down making it kind of look like a walk
but it just more looks like someone's
limping so it doesn't really work so
well but screw it I mean yeah it's
better nothing
yeah that's supposed to be a loading bar
as well like because it takes so long
people don't realize and they try and
drag it they're like huh you can't drag
it it is a loading bus but yeah the game
just takes a while so just bear with me
there you go
this song was the bane of my existence
when I was making this game I swear I
was carrying crazy weight ones like oh I
can't take it okay whatever I was going
absolutely crazy I'll put like four or
five in the morning trying to get this
finished for deadlines and I was just
like running on caffeine just like doo
da doo da so to me this this sound has
like a whole new meaning but anyway so I
did this I made it like come across the
screen like it looks like a like a
digital thing now look on a computer or
whatever
hey gwaan hey darlin and I also
implemented this so that you have to use
your information enter the correct
information yeah cuz I was like oh they
don't actually feel anything in I'm not
gonna have anything to put into my bits
also my bits my fingers very well that's
that's me I put all my songs in here as
a girl Easter Egg but anyway yes so once
you put your name in here like
it's gonna update it doesn't update much
it just updates the end folder the door
oh she uh she originally let's talk
about this so originally it was supposed
to be this was supposed to be what am I
saying the Facebook thing yeah so I was
using the Facebook SDK and after this I
might see if I can get up some videos
because I was so proud of myself I
managed to make it so I asked the player
to log in with their Facebook account
and then it got their name it got a
random name of their friend and put that
see you know that door where you can
peep into it I'll show you it later if
you haven't played the game that
actually had one of your friends names
on it and it was supposed to and toast
you that way so you'd see like a
friend's name you'd be like oh like let
me look at the chat like you were like
oh I know torque mg like what what are
they doing there and then and then you'd
look in and it actually worked and I got
your profile picture and I saved it as a
material so I could upload then that
material update that material to any
object any 3d object in the game that I
had and it was gonna be so cool I was
gonna have like little pictures around
the game and then you'd be like oh he'll
so that's me in the picture um but then
you know the whole controversy about
Facebook came around and their security
just went through the roof they did not
allow any new apps to be made for I
think it was up to six months or
something without it going through this
like rigorous process where they had to
make sure that everything was okay and
it wasn't using information in a bad way
and I did not have that time because I
needed to get the game down for
deadlines for university for third year
or house I would not have had my degree
so I had to do this instead and this was
asking
questions and stuff like that I got the
idea because I was watching my friend
play em until dawn again and I was like
it's pretty cool how they ask you to
choose pictures and stuff so maybe I'll
just do that oh wow
so yeah anyway I will show you stuff
like that lay em and I would love if I
can find the time to go back to my
original Facebook idea because I got the
code working I've still got that code so
I would love to use it somewhere but
anyway so let's see and the girl that
it's me also other I didn't want to
exclude anyone but we didn't have time
to meet like an other model because the
the model the character artist Tabitha
if she's still here made um male female
she made the monster and I'm really
sorry but I changed that wants to deter
because I just Terra's like my monster
and I love him so much but yeah and then
other was gonna be I don't know we never
really got around that we just wanted to
include everyone and then yeah so now
it's like so this is the image bit and
my friend Nina made these because it was
very last minute as I said the whole
Facebook thing just threw me off
completely guys can someone say if you
can hear me or not cuz like no one's
complaining but no one says that they
can hear me and I'm ready I'm really
worried that I'm gonna watch this back
and just realize it's just me singing
and no one could really hear what I'm
saying
because I can turn the game down a
little bit but anyway yeah so the mirror
is supposed to represent physical
attraction so if you're more worried
about your appearance or the the
physicality of things in theory you'd
pick this one this one the eye it's all
about being judged and the fear of being
judged by others and then the little
silhouette of a person is the fear of
being alone or the fear of abandonment I
sound good cool thank you what language
used to program this game disturbia this
C sharp C sharp in unity
freedom please oh yeah the correct sorry
Jamie okay um so which one's my favorite
I think my favorite is the I won so I'm
going to show you that but there's a
three different they make little changes
oh by the way that song that you just
heard that version of sweater is the
version from the EP you put it in a
little looser Matt see you soon thank
you please make yourself at home
while we prepare your journey to
perfection cheers Jamie okay so if you
look up here it says please be patient
and you can't go through there yeah the
lock sound is so quiet I need to make it
bigger and I added like a little noise
on the TV because I wanted people to be
curious well what it was see now it says
please enter yeah c'mon X cheers Jamie
but yeah if you look at this sorry taps
but she does anyway
stack and yeah sugar sweet goo let's
turn this off cuz I'm just gonna get
ready so you can press it easy turn this
off by the way I don't know if everyone
knows this so we have e to inspect and
then left mouse to interact so you can
also turn these around Wow
so what I did in the latest update I
made an update like the other days it's
nothing that big but I just put a light
on the examine camera because a lot of
people couldn't read these so what these
are is and also I don't think a lot of
people know this these are real comments
from people in my comment section
I asked while I was making the game yeah
I asked while I was making the game
while I was in the development process
what people would think that their
imperfections were and this was it so
this person said perfect me and yeah and
what they would change to meet
themselves fair
so this is a prayer for me would have
short black hair instead of my shaved
head
I'd be slimmer but still stocky I'd like
to be more confident in myself and be
more tech savvy and then um I don't know
what I've written there I've got this in
a windowed mode because just in case I
needed to get out of it but underneath
it the very bottom obviously the text is
a bit too small then I need to make it
bigger I made it bigger I need to make a
bigger again I've like responded to
everyone in my comment section and so
one thing I would love to do is do more
of those because I wanted to personally
give my input on what you guys had said
where your imperfections or or anything
like that so there's like there's one
and it says something like I wish I was
more intelligent and then I had put in
the comment below into like emotional
intelligence or or book smarts like
because there's a loads of different
types of intelligence and it's sad that
some people think they're not smart when
there's a bunch of different ways to be
smart you know I mean um anyway let's
move over to here
my fireflies this is like one of the
first things that I made and I was so
proud of them they're all slightly
different shades of like green I think
it is like turquoise and white and if
you see they have little tiny trails and
and they're going around in like
randomly all that cloudy motions but the
faster they go the longer the trail gets
and I did this using the particle system
I mean don't look at that grass grass is
ugly but I'm so proud of my little
Firefly so happy yeah what people say in
the chat I will download it thank you
did you do any play testing for this
early part did you end up choosing a lot
in this area so the play taste thing we
just asked like our friends and people
in our course to play tests so yeah we
did do that and then obviously my
Tabitha and Tiffany played it as well
because I was I was coding it and then I
would spend all night look at this
thing thinking this is gross so they
played it to to keeping an actual
insight and yeah
what have we change oh damn I wish
Tiffany was here so I'm gonna put Tiff's
Twitter in the description after I
upload this I'll actually do it now as
well in the chat because TIFF is the
environment designer and I know she did
change some stuff so dude that's the
environment designer because I can't
really what why did she change things
she she changed it
they're just double-checking
everything's good everything's good yep
I think we changed this no we didn't
change the window I always wanted a big
long window to look outside you wanted
it to look modernistic we wanted the big
TV Wow that was supposed to be a TV that
was going to be looping that trailer
that I played through the beginning but
instead we turned it I bury last Manoj
she turned it into a security cam for
that little jump scare at the end and
yeah we knew the a big part of games and
making games believable we're just like
having these little things like little
little bits and bobs scattered and some
people have said that in the feedback
and that makes me so happy because it
means that people have realized and it's
done its job because you know if you
have big empty environments that just
don't look lived in I don't have objects
it just doesn't really work so like we
have here you know out to lunch it's
like oh damn I'm on my own this person
is out for lunch I also did have a
mechanic that I took out where you could
pick things up so you could press the
left left like and like pick it up and
then move it around and stuff but hey
you didn't need to do this there was
this you know point and B they kept
going through the walls so I was like
you don't need to do this and it keeps
bugging out anyway I'm just gonna delete
it but you don't understand how
difficult that is when you've spent
and a piece of code and then you don't
even end up using it but oh well see
yeah we have like magazines here and
that's the company logo the company is
never better and the company is never
better
the the product is the perfection
headset so this is the thing like the
more that we put around the room of the
rooms the more we were like building up
the narrative and making it seem more
immersive making it more believable if
you know what I mean like why is
perfection necessary just like tiny
little things like that you know also
someone sent me an email like earlier on
today saying that there's something
about the texture on the bottom of this
oh my god there's yeah there's a word on
the bottom of this bowl and I'm Tiffany
I'm gonna tell safe I hope that's not
like a trademark kind of thing
embarrassing but anyway someone did so
that's me today so yeah we have these
posters as well though that actually
TIFF made these ones and they're really
cool [ __ ] there's a man and a female get
ready and prepare for a perfection and I
made these ones the illustration one and
that was supposed to be the whole idea
of the the company is like it's all kind
of kaleidoscope II and it's about making
the inner you as perfect and as
beautiful as it can be but anyway let's
let's carry on so um yeah we have all
this you can open these you can see is
another one of these here my floors that
I always know that I have to do
important things for me and everyone
else and they try hard to do it but I
never do and in consequence I disappoint
people I love to be perfect I would
change my attribute of laziness to put
productivity so I would never let down
my friends and family again
see it's so like the answers like God
would just so uh I just want to help
everyone but also well
suitable as well there you go you have
the music so the idea of having that
there was to get them used to knowing
that they can peep into stores because
if we're gonna have the only one people
board or four then we were like none of
that well the one major one but then we
were like now we need to have something
so that they already know that mechanic
is okay and then this is the one where
it's gonna judge them whether they
actually do people not because they know
that they should not peep into this one
also I know the audio is so bad it's um
you went to Jamie's recording studio
we're just like whispers I don't know I
need somebody just like oh yeah also
notice these nothing's gonna happen now
but notice that I chose the I at the
beginning of the game
and now all the portraits are closed
eyes and remember I told you that the I
was about being scared of judgement
being judged even though I like my
solitude as a part of me that's worried
about being alone forever
I can relate so this this it does the
does the job because people I'm I've
actually do have a man in there spoilers
there is a man in there but I forgotten
to put the texture I need to do that
still um but yeah he doesn't have a
texture on him but it's working anyway
because um when I watched my friend play
he was like it's a song in there and I
didn't even realize that you could look
through the peoples till I was playing
it just before deadline I was like this
is freaking Queen and yeah fact that you
can see here this cool so anyway
the code for this changed so many times
I had it so like you had to click on the
peephole to pee but the people was too
small and it just getting really fiddly
so I ended up putting this extra camera
in so you had this extra piece of like
gooey no UI so you can choose and it
makes it more obvious that you're doing
something that's probably me not should
be done may not should be done that
probably shouldn't be done hopefully
making you like stop and thing can be
like wait should I do this do I want to
do this cuz the other door was just too
normal and then this one's supposed to
kind of invoke some sort of anxiety why
that girls cry so much oh yes she does
cry that was very last minute as well I
just wanted something freaky maybe
actually just left it silent but anyway
so I'm gonna peep yeah this is a
last-minute decision to see I am so glad
that people found that dude scary
because I literally immense as you are
warned so it knows now I've got a
boolean that was checking to see whether
you were gonna people not that boolean
has now been changed from false to true
because you did peek and that means
different things gonna happen now so I
mean you get this text this year you
were warned you were warned thing isn't
gonna happen and that also changes the
ending this was glitched for a very long
time the ending was always the peeped
ending
but now it's now I've updated this now a
60s textbook
yeah but I didn't think that was scary
but I keep seeing people like jumping it
and I'm like yeah it makes me happy
other by the way that's me it's my eye
yes great glad glad you liked it
okay let's carry on you've can't press
shift to run just just saying okay so
this is interesting as well because we
had we had interesting environment
design choices for this I asked the
environment artists to put panels in
front of the perfection headset
mannequin this was supposed to be a get
basically a replication of Silent Hill
Homecoming I know it's not the best one
but there's a part in the beginning of
homecoming that just stuck with me
because it's actually to be fair I think
they do this in the oldest son Hill
games anyway I just remember homecoming
because it was the newest one where you
go into this room and you can't see
because the camera angles shifting and
you know you're going through and then
suddenly once the camera angle gets back
in place there's a mannequin but it's
behind the capice of cloth so all you
see is the shadow and it looks like it's
gonna be a creature it's gonna kill you
so you kind of freak out a bit that's
why they wanted for this but we couldn't
get the textures working so that's
probably something else that I need to
look into but then maybe that's
something that we need to change in like
Maya or something like outside of unity
I think making the material outside
sorry thought someone's at my door
anyway but that was that was supposed to
be it was supposed to be like this
dramatic shadow thing but it kind of
maybe works cuz you can only just see
the head but you can tell basically
straight away that it's a mannequin head
but that is that is why I made this
dramatic shadow here cuz I thought you
know I don't know if you're not freaked
out you might be like wait why is that
freaking head oh oh it's a mannequin
head oh you know because you might think
that it's a severed head or something
gross but yeah anyway I asked the
environment artists to do these panels
and to to make this one oh yeah the
doors closed behind you because that's
always the thing in horror games right
but anyway yeah so facing this way like
angled a bit because I wanted the people
the people's to walk this way and look
at this but a lot of people are walking
this way and I'm like huh
that didn't really work today I guess
maybe they're going towards the light
but yeah it's supposed to go here they
don't have to but it just kind of um
tells you a bit more about the headset
gives you some information so that you
know you know what you're putting on
your head basically and also just to add
to that sense of immersion and realism
you know yeah so then it's all very
dramatic here yeah boy and so yeah it's
funny that I knew exactly where that
trigger was anyway
so yeah so Suze you were there it's like
whoa it's also Brighton it's so big and
this is the perfection headset oh my
gosh this is what we've been waiting for
and look it's a mannequin head it's just
out of ZBrush is very low poly now see
yeah this is the perfection headset
pretty proud of it thank you
then you put it on and just yeah just
you wait
okay so this is the first the first jump
- this is using a lot of different
different effects so it's using like a
shaky cam that sorry that breathing so
it's using a shaky cam the shakes when
you're near to the monster that
breathing is yeah that breathing is the
monster but I think it's also you okay
yeah yeah so pretty good here no Hawaii
music and when you go up to it when you
shake you kind of lose control of your
mouth a little bit I was trying to like
make you lose control because that's
that's kind of freaky and I'm spooky in
whatever so okay
yeah if you go towards the monster it
starts to cry and then
where the hell did that go and one thing
I would love to bring to your attention
please
if you haven't already noticed because
it took me for ages for ages forever is
that if you chose that you're a male
your noises are male if you chose that
you're a female your noises of female
and the same thing goes to the monster
because the monster spoilers the monster
is a reflection of yourself and it's
everything imperfect about you so yeah
so that that crying that wheezing it's
either gonna be female wheezing or male
wheezing if it's male wheezing or crying
then it's Jamie and if it's female then
it's me yeah so yeah anyway it's all
creepy now it's like weather how'd it go
I'm I'm pooping out oh my gosh
oh yeah and as you as you will see the
the furnitures changed there's like
fallen down chairs and stuff and the
posters just not quite right and stuff
like that that is yeah that's basically
it was like hidden hidden objects that
only got so I had to group everything so
it was like before
props and after props after props are
instantiated when she put the headset on
and the before props are then deleted
but I know it's not left this bloody
chair and it's supposed to be in there
before props I'm literally taking all
the magic away so this chair was
supposed to translate into that falling
down chair but instead they're just you
know it's just on top of it I mean I
guess chaos madness everywhere seeing
you open this it's quite funny because
when we were doing play testing we some
people were like oh if we call it the
music changed you know to make it more
creepy you know like I had just you wait
some people like this some people didn't
and I totally understand why supposed to
kind of make you feel confused and
uneasy which we should just do everyone
I've seen a play this has been very
confused but every time you hit a glitch
it's like the same song but it's
supposed to be slowly like turning into
something else
Sam Hill was among a life Silent Hill
was a massive inspiration for this game
hey exotic and hey Amir and hey Jackson
Jack thank you so much for coming dude I
realize that in the game you use your
voices sound effects like the start
radio
yes I do disturb you yeah those are my
songs you can find all those songs on my
my youtube channel that anyway yeah so
some Hill was a massive inspiration for
this game I'm not going to lie
we even looked at PT and we were trying
to like see how they made their balls
and stuff I actually uh oh my gosh I
actually found people have found
development bits left from PT and there
was
the model and the normal map for the
hallway and I was very intrigued because
it also had the kind of texture map as
well but it showed a bunch of different
textures like on one more like this you
would have loads of different colors and
different colors amounts to different
texture sheets which they just had so
much texture but if you look at the game
it just it kind of looks like a normal
war but I think for every time he likes
to scrape on the bump and stuff like
that they had it they had a different
different texture put onto that and oh
my gosh it blew me away but we did not
have the time to do that
so what we did do was we added oh sorry
we added a normal map onto the walls and
made them look as if they had more
texture like 3d texture so you can see
these bumps and stuff and that panel as
well so it looks more like 3d it kind of
looks like it's coming out and it's a
bit rippled and stuff like that that the
wall isn't like that it's literally just
what you can kind of tell is it's just a
straight up down but it's the normal map
that makes it look textured and I know
that Tiffany spent forever on that and
we were both extremely proud of it also
what you can do now is this so if you
look at the portraits they they open the
right so remember I said I chose the eye
which means I don't like to be judged I
don't like to be looked at in a sense
you know watched so I'm being watched if
I watch them
[Music]
boobies okay so um this it's supposed to
represent the peeping aspect and don't
forget I was gonna incorporate Facebook
at the beginning and this door was
supposed to have your friends name on it
which is oh my god Amy he's so creepy
we're supposed to have your friend's
name on it so in essence you're peeping
on your friend and then on your way back
your friend will be peeping on you I did
think of that I was like what if you
click the door and then it goes into the
Pete mode so you're just facing knocking
on the door if you go up and you hit it
anyway walk away you go back there's
nothing so hopefully that freaks some
people out the idea of that was from
alone in the dark a new nightmare the
ps1 game not the PST games ridiculous
[Music]
because yeah there's just a bit in the
start of that game that I will never
forget where you literally just walking
outside the house you're trying to get
into the house this is if you chose is
it can be do I remember that right if I
remember though I'm so proud of myself
car can't be anyway you should want to
get into the house and you just walk
around you like and there's suddenly
because it's fixed camera angle points
back in the ps1 days it changes and
there's it's the camera angles coming
from inside the house watching you
outside the house and you can just hear
like a like something breathing and it's
like moving like this so you can tell
it's it's something watching you and it
unnerved the Halla because I did not see
it coming because every other camera
angle yes it was third-person but it was
behind you wasn't first person from an
eye monsters perspective so that that
was great I loved that anyway so now you
have these things you have blood packs
and unfortunate I'm to text you like
each individual one but yes so we have
the blood packs and stuff just to make
you feel a bit more uneasy we also I
don't know if anyone's notice but the
leaves are dead so then they were like
nice nice like friendly what no lively
alive they were alive and now they are
dead okay this friendly leads we also
this was another design idea because I
wanted them to notice that
then being you by the way I wanted you
didn't notice great job on the game
Thank You exotic I knew I felt a PT vibe
to this yes attack of life no you
definitely did yes I wanted them so no
to say if you look at the portraits
things are happening and and hopefully
the fact that the portraits are actual
photographs that actual real people
would also be more unnerving so I asked
the Tiffany the environment artists to
put this here this picture of my friend
Nina my lovely friend Nina because then
hopefully you you will be looking at it
when you're walking down here and you
would notice where as with all these
ones you could easily walk past them and
there's no way that you're going to
interact with them unless you actually
look at them so yeah I was hoping that
that would be the case some people
haven't noticed some people have so it's
quite interesting to see but anyway this
this I am very proud of okay this is
called the Hitchcock effect the vertical
camera effects whatever you want to call
it and it's it's basically we're in film
they do it a lot where is it they're
zooming out but moving forward and it
gives us kind of warped feel to it
and yes sir works and it kind of feels
that you're never going to get to the
end of the hallway
but then you do
then you're back again now some people
like this some people did and some
people were like oh my gosh it's just
like PT but don't forget this game it
kind of was based on PT and hopefully if
that shadow didn't get you the first
time I think that without flickering one
it's pretty darn creepy anyway so so I'm
gonna have the idea of changing this
when you get sent back in and I bloody
well agree I think that's a change that
I need to make definitely by the way if
anyone here has like input on what they
would like like to see in the game or
whatever in the future or if you want me
to carry on making this like do let me
know but I'm a one gal band at the
moment so yeah this it's it's totally
changed now the appearance has totally
changed
there's handprints like blood prints
like on the wall I've put the shininess
up which makes it look kind of like damp
and just just a bit dirty and I quite
liked how that looks when if you do look
at PT you'll notice the floor is quite
shiny reflects a lot off and I think
that gives a really kind of eerie effect
especially when you have lights and
stuff to bounce off hey Don Choi hey
rugs can fly so many people from Mexico
Croatia thanks idolan Colombia that's
Jacob oh cool cool cool just found out
about your channel and this game there's
nothing anywhere look yeah oh and as you
see the final image now is the one the
Aussie but yeah you can close them again
if you if you take the time you can
close them again if you face your fear
apparently mine was um being watched so
now all the eyes just watching me and
it's fantastic
okay so I had a lot of questions about
this um basically the thing with the
pregnancy test was we were gonna have
assets already look that was supposed to
freak out male and females but like on
their own so and we're gonna have
graffiti on the walls that would be
specific to genders to kind of make you
feel of you you personally were being
targeted so for the graffiti for
instance we were gonna have like [ __ ]
or [ __ ] or something like that it was
horrible but I think every girl has had
to deal with that kind of name being
thrown at her we weren't too sure like
oh you know for men like maybe like men
don't cry or Oh like worse or something
like that yeah like not strong enough or
something and then to the assets we
thought you know females would kind of
be able to what's the word
associate the fear of being pregnant
like when you don't maybe don't want to
be pregnant or like you know it's a
scary time if you're pregnant
I don't know I wouldn't know but I might
do one day and like I'm sure if you
explain this lovely but you know I think
every girl has had like a moment where
they're like oh my gosh so that was that
but then we never got around to making
anyone's for males because hey we were
an all-girl team we didn't really know
and plus we ran out of time completely
but I wanted the environment artists to
still get graded on it so we kept them
in that's literally the reason this I
think is my best
jump-scare and it I literally am moving
like I made it
two nights beforehand in I just thought
it needed something a bit extra and that
was it oh also these so these drag marks
if I get the time in the future or if I
had more time back then I wanted to your
first playthrough I wanted to have
random noises playing get triggered and
that sounded like something was behind
you so like you turn the corner and
you'd hear something else turn a corner
and that's what was supposed to
represent these drag marks so it's
supposed to be like you heard something
was following you you couldn't see it
though and even if you walked out it was
not there but then you got transported
back and you could see all these drag
marks so that's from what was following
you that was the premise but we ran out
of time again so yeah this actually has
changed a lot I'll show you what it is
now why are you watching
[Music]
so that jump-scare was going to be
different completely different and I
still don't understand why the codes
stopped working but it stopped working
pretty much the day before deadline and
it was a webcam and basically when you
walk when you looked in there they're
not no they're not did they're not
happen I don't I can't remember but um
you looked in here and it was an image
of you like a live image of you playing
the webcam play in the webcam playing
the game basically so you were looking
back at yourself I'm gonna still see if
I can make that work and then have this
as a backup if the person doesn't have a
webcam attached or something like that
but basically I had it working so that
checked whether you had a webcam if it
did have the webcam that great it made
it active and that was gonna be the
plate but for some reason
two days before deadline or something so
there there it just stopped working and
I got very very stress I stayed up all
night did this stupid eyeball one of
them wants to do with it texture in it
making it shiny but yeah that's what it
turned into and I think it has turned
into one of the best jumps yet so I am
pretty happy with it anyway let's carry
on when did you start working on this
game good question Jamie oh what's up
Masami he said the city we're at the
mannequin head scared you a bit yes yeah
and Jamie's here Jamie is the dude from
Horizon productions the the sound demon
what was it saying when die so I can so
we started
working on this I guess I'd like the end
of September but that wasn't like we
didn't start making this game that was
literally from concept to to everything
so that was you know wondering are we
gonna make a horror game are we gonna
make a fantasy game what kind of game
remember that's when we said like when
we actually started to code it and put
it into unity was probably more around
December time and then we finished it
June so it was made yeah so there's many
like seven ish months but conceptually
Wow okay well if it's thank you but I
can get me I didn't realize was looking
at that bloody thing I'm gonna explain
to you first you know anyway and you
turned around and he's not that but
anyway game to relegate can't scared for
her own game well that's good thing but
yeah so these all of this by the way
they they have oh my girl for years they
have what is known as a Shriver was of
course
rigid body that's what they have they
have a rigid body so when the monster
comes because basically what what that
was was I did have it so that if you
clicked on this that would happen but
then I realized most people weren't even
clicking on the security camera sorry
then I made it just like if you
literally briefly looked at it for a
second it forced you to look like this
and it teleported the monster behind you
so major jump-scare but yeah and because
the the monster doesn't teleport in a
single sport just teleports wherever you
are in the room - think it was wild see
I think it was said which is behind so
where are we like I could be here I
could be here I could be here like
wherever the hell I was in this room he
would just end up being right dead
center behind me which is a very
important thing because then you're
supposed to be like oh my gosh do I get
office here at camera - a turnaround
what do I do
one thing that I'm actually thinking of
it's like when you come off you can
still see it so I should have made it
black so that you're not sure if he's
still behind you or not and then you
have to turn around
that'd be freakier that just came to me
right then but yeah this idea it's
another one that was inspired to me by
another horror game I've had a very
expensive extensive life of playing hard
games I love horror games but the
suffering I don't know if any was paid
that one it's a little bit more obscure
but the suffering I think was a great
horror game the first one anyone so come
on soso but was on ps2 and they had this
security cam mechanic where you could
dude there was like a little computer on
the table you click on the computer and
then it it shows you different security
cams and then you kind of click through
and you can see like loads of random
different ones sometimes you see like
other characters and there sometimes you
see people getting killed by the creek
years but there's this one time it's
only happens once where you're clicking
through clicking through and the
suddenly you're like wait that's me
that's me this security cameras in the
room that I'm in and then you're like
watching yourself and the one of the
monsters just slowly starts to walk up
behind you and if I remember rightly
it's not just like one click to go out
the security cameras I think it's like
two clicks or something like that to get
fully out so I obviously freaking out
with my playstation rumor and like oh my
gosh and like a gal of the security
camera turnaround like waiting to just
kill this thing and it's not there and
then I go back in the security camera
nothing happens and it just freaked me
out it was so good it was such a good
little scare tactic but yeah so that
that's what happened there also there's
these needles that kind of creepy
so may even pick this up no
which I have also forgotten to make
interactable that's that's kind of
embarrassing
I thought you can pick them up ah
whatever another pregnancy test um oh do
you guys want me to spoil the Easter egg
okay I will don't look if you don't want
the Easter eggs I made this project so
basically if you want to know more about
my project and how I feel about it I'm
so oblong it's on the radio
it's about ho I mean far from practical
it is so I made this and oh yeah
it's just me and my friends like playing
around with some audio software making
us sound like monsters well we do now
does anyone know that's for him it's
doctor hey so creepy it's me laughing
like a monster anyway yeah so this bit
does confuse people a lot but I'm quite
happy with the time that people spend
here this to take me a while to figure
out because what's first happen is
you're supposed to go towards the exit
so I had to really make this dramatic
like exit go to the exit and if you
notice at the beginning of the game it's
green but now it's red and I like to
turn off and it's like oh and then this
door opens but that still probably could
be more obvious that is also why these
scratch marks I like by the door also if
you notice the posters have changed as
well like the man it's got a skull on
now yeah so we're creeping a bit boo-ki
[Music]
so yeah but I had to make sure that this
one was lot like is it see it's not
Lucknow so you can go back to the few
one but as soon as you do this the audio
changes so you know you've made a
progression the game and you hear a door
open but you not sure where it is and
it's this one and if you try to go
through here you can't its lot because
before people were going back through
here and I was like no so I had to lock
it so yeah you can't go back see there
I'm afraid
okay then we got this and actually here
is there's a visible box that times you
on how long it takes for you to get to
the monster so the monsters called
terror by the way and this is actually
what tells you how brave you are if you
spend forever it says you're coward
basically and if you go straight over to
it was like yeah you were so brave so
anyways let's go up and then you start
to do a little like
and then there you go it's the end of
the game and you are the monster how did
I make this mirror texture you asked I'm
very glad you asked no one asked
everyone's talking about the the doctor
oh yeah Jamie Jamie Jamie Jamie Jamie
Jamie problem bear wants to know what
audio software did you use but yes it
turns like your ear and you're like oh
my gosh I'm the monster Wow look at my
claws look at my little bony hands look
at my boobs like I look fabulous
you can't move or anything because you
just can't okay just can't do that
and then here it's like a patient named
yak my neck that's that'd be me so as I
said I chose the the eye which is
supposed to represent the fear of
judgment which I think very much
represents me and then I try to think
about this like logically I tried to
still keep it within the narrative so I
was like how would you change that
within the brain I am no neuroscientist
but you know I have Google on my side so
I can I can like Google stuff and
basically yeah I said imperfections
target the fear of judgment self-worth
must be enlarged 'end and not reply not
reply not rely on other attributes can
reward the other ones say but you can
find out if you choose another picture
so this is the patient curious about
their environment their curiosity makes
them hyper aware of their surroundings
because I was looking at everything I
picked up quite a few things I was a
very curious beaver
if you don't look at very much stuff
then you're not curious and you stay
focused it says that you stay focus does
the patient follow orders no they made
their own decisions no matter the risk
that's because I peeped in the door this
did happen all the time to say that all
the time but I've changed that now so it
should say something like yes they obey
orders
if you don't peep in the door did the
patient
reaction when faced with danger they are
fearful of the truth I took too long to
go towards the monster and both
scenarios actually it was the beginning
one when you first learn monster and the
end one so I'm fearful and yeah then the
patient means in perfect if you remain
imperfect then you exit the game if you
restart the system then you get sent
back to the main menu but I'm just gonna
say that I'm still imperfect so you're
not very perfect you will never be
perfect that's okay because no one will
ever be perfect because no one is
perfect that's the whole point of the
game which I think some people don't
realize some more like why are you
trying to make me perfect and I'm like
no I've trying to make you feel okay but
not be perfect but um yeah I will
actually explain to you now while we
have a bit more time starting to go make
dinner now but my the whole concept and
premise of this was made in you only
have those nights for you're up all
night and you you think you're just
thinking you just your brain is going
overload on so many different things
that's what was happening I was in bed I
could not sleep and I was just like I
wish I wish I wish I wish I could play a
guitar I wish I could do this I wish I
could do that I wish I could get this
finished I wish I could do everything I
wish I could fall asleep right now oh I
wish I wish I wish I wish basically and
then I was like why can't I why can't it
why can't I play the guitar very well
why can't I you know making video
everyday for YouTube why can't I do all
these things that they want to do
because I can't focus because I'm trying
to do them all at once because I just I
could be perfect at them I could be who
I want to be on all these things if I
just took out everything that got in the
way everything that that distracted me
then I was like okay so how do I do this
so I thought what if the government
makes like a headset Oh something
someone makes a headset you put the
headset on and then it's got this sort
of like bit in it that um stores like
all your procrastinate thoughts like
everything that you know everything that
gets in the way of you being perfect
gets stored within the headset so that
you can just be focused on what you
wanna be
but then I was like hmm what would that
be exactly what would we put into the
headset Wow you like literally your
personality everything that makes you
you everything but because if you
procrastinate it's usually because it's
something that you're interested in or
it's a job that you found funny like
it's something to do with you as a
person to your personality and then if
you had a headset on that made you
perfect it made you just like focus on
something that would essentially make
you a robot like literally everything
that is you would be stored in that
headset and then I was like what better
way for government to control a whole
civilization then to make this headset I
know this is like it's crazy and the
game when he touches on like a tiny bit
of the idea but that was basically it
that was basically it and then I was
like ah you know I can make this cool
like it just started off as me thinking
of an idea for YouTube also make this
cool advert that's kind of like Bioshock
II and it's like make perfection yours
make perfection you but actually it's
all like messed up and the whole idea
and premise of it is just not okay like
making people think that they should be
perfect but that's essentially what
marketing does and advertising does
anyway it's just telling us how when
imperfect and we need to be perfected to
be perfect we just buy this product so
this is basically like an enlarged
version of what it already happens in
the media you are overthinking a lot I
overthink everything that's who I am and
that's also why I wanted me against
designer because I think it's a good
trait to have it's like you take a lot
of things on board you overthink you
always always always ask why you never
stop asking you're just like okay this
but why this but how this but why that
but could
and it's all part of the fun that's some
cyberpunk themed idea exactly like I
think there's so much more that can be
done with it I'd love to like write a
story make more films make more of this
game perhaps cuz I don't know I'm just
so over so overblown so overblown so
overwhelmed with them just how how many
people played it how many people have
already enjoyed the concept and just
yeah how many people liked it so blood
and animals interesting combination for
your game oh that's true okay thank you
I was just back afterwards by the way so
if you did say anything about the game
or like ideas for the game and I haven't
said anything about them now I'm gonna
be watching back so dude you do put them
in doo doo doo doo doo Tim for hat stuff
exactly mantas tinfoil hat stuff hey mo
thanks for the smiley face the same
Geordi wild Sam what is Geordi well say
him I don't know I always thought that
horror games with the flash lights are
good I do actually have a flashlight but
it's very dim but I could turn it up if
you think that would help
I haven't uncovered I guess because then
I could just like instead of having the
whole lights at the end of the game like
the flashing dramatic hall lights I
could have the spotlight
yeah actually or I can even just make
the spotlight brighter for that part and
then hopefully like you slowly uncover
it is you're coming down the hall that
could be creepier oh yes oh yes I like
these ideas oh yes like haven't ya how
haven't it how often do you shave your
legs
this is ridiculous question you why yeah
why
Havas me to most the time asking a lot
about existence self exactly adilyn like
I don't know just keep doing it keep
doing it I think it's a good thing cuz
like I used to do it loads when I was a
kid I remember just
I honestly thought I had superpowers
when I was a kid I'm not even kidding
you I just used to think the stupidest
things were like superpowers but that
was where my imagination came from and
that was where I used to write a lot of
stories when I was a kid that's where it
all came from and I just think a lot of
like logic and I don't know stuff gets
thrown at us when we're adults and we
think that overthinking or being curious
or like maybe just being a bit
outlandish is ridiculous as we're an
adult but that's how you stay creative
like in my experience and from what I've
seen and watched and heard of other
people that I look up to that's how they
stay creative and that's how they get
such pretty ideas because they they just
never stop questioning and they never
they never grow up essentially they're
always that they're always a kid just
trying to find out more and wondering
different ways of thinking but maybe
this happens because of this even if it
doesn't it's like you were what if it
did and that's that's an idea you know I
mean surely wild is the you to be played
your game is that the the Spanish one I
don't I don't know what you said but I
enjoyed it and I did watch his I did
watch him play and I saw his like jump
scares and stuff it was very funny it
made me laugh
awesome yeah madhouse do let me know if
you play this game thank you so much I'm
gonna have to go now like unless anyone
has any burning questions I will answer
them right before I go but what I will
do is I will leave just some like some
music playing for you and you can put in
your your ideas about the game maybe if
you have stuff that you want me to
implement in let me know if you want me
to carry on working more on it if you
want me to whack on a different game
instead anything like that I'll keep up
the livestream for a little bit and then
I can look back on it back on afterwards
hey 1001 speedster too busy to watch the
stream yikes
that's no worries thank you for coming
I'm gonna keep this one live anyway so
if you're ever born you've got like an
hour
kill you canyou can watch it when I was
a child already how he put his pastor
and when I opened my eyes the coke would
be gone
my mother would hide it that's so cute
[Laughter]
ah any parrot that can get involved in
their kids imagination like that is like
yes a star parenting I love that I love
a love a love it what I'll also do for
you is so Jamie from Horizon Productions
put the soundtrack way there let me get
it up put the soundtrack on his
SoundCloud and I think if you guys like
the the audio then definitely check it
out so I think you'll enjoy that
goodbye Facebook why you why are you
here
Jamie wait I'll put in here horizon
productions perfection soundtrack don't
leave that's my question
oh I like tags Asik when you're walking
down the hallway the lights break so you
have to use your flashlight dad's very
nice that's very nice yeah I like that a
lot
good idea so this is great like I I was
doing gamedev streams while I was making
in the game and I just think it's so
much better when you can get like a
community involved this is why indie
devs are the best well I don't know no I
mean it would be nice to have live team
that actually knew what they were doing
like that would be so nice cuz I'm on my
own right now now that you needs
finished
everyone's we're all like dispersed and
I'm the only coder I would be so nice to
have another coder who like knew how to
code cuz I think I know how to code but
a lot of it is a lot of it it's just
Google and then debug debug
bug you know I hope you play life is
strange oh I need to but I need money to
buy yeah I haven't been able to afford
yeah but I'm hoping I'm doing some like
lecturing in the university next week so
I'm hoping to get it and as soon as I do
I promise you I will stream life is
strange because I cannot wait to play
that game I I'm actually really excited
to play that game I've also been trying
to find a way of playing Silent Hill for
you guys but it seems really difficult
and it's like 60 pounds to buy a second
hand and apparently even if you do it's
really difficult to get to run on on
later pcs well alright yeah good pcs so
I don't know but yeah I am definitely
serving up a lot of strange don't worry
about that I'll play it soon and yeah
fixed time work angle like wasn't evil
exactly but I would love sunhill
especially after making this game and I
am still obsessed with PT like to this
day if anyone makes a youtube video
about PT I bet you I am watching that
like straight away I've been trying to
actually write a song about it but I
just can't get the lyrics right and I
think I think I'm too invested
have you found a job no not not in the
game industry yet I'm still applying but
I have had well I had some like office
which were lovely but it wasn't enough
to like move because I don't live
anywhere near anywhere so it sucks I
mean I would love to just take out
people's offers but unfortunately I need
to I need to make sure I can live as
well so yeah I am still looking but I do
have a job next week I've been offered
some lecturing shindig so I'm gonna be
teaching some students there's a pretty
hope that they like me I don't know and
I just hope they're not like I'm sure we
find it's University I'm sure we fine I
don't think depth that surrounding is a
PG spin-off it's not um hey Dave already
said it's not horror I know you can like
folly trust everything that he says but
he's already said it's not a horror game
and everything that I've seen him that
game is just like not Petey it's just so
so different I'm still very looking
forward to death training do not get me
wrong and anything that that man and
grammar does horror make together is
gonna be amazing and they really
freaking hope they still have Junjie Ito
on their side because when I heard
judging Ito was gonna be on PT I flipped
my lid I was like yes but um yeah damn
what am i teaching I'm teaching um
Photoshop and illustrator next week and
then after that I'm teaching coding so C
sharp and unity3d but after next week
I'll just be like an assistant so I'll
just be just be in the classroom just
hey you need help ba ba ba but ya know
tomorrow I'm actually gonna be on my own
in delivering lectures so it's gonna be
it's gonna be interesting anyway I'm
gonna go now I'm gonna leave you with
some music do let me know if you have
ideas if you ex
to see more if you want me to just stop
on this and start with something else
let me know and I will read back through
them so yeah anyway thank you so so much
for joining me I will say goodbye to
whoever I can see in the comments so hey
Rick Jeezy and thank you for coming to
the channel but also goodbye but I hope
you watch other content I have just
published a game on itch so maybe you
played that it's in the description did
you
good bye Lucas goodbye Eleanor goodbye
Pepe Pepe goodbye Adaline could buy
exotic by Jackson Jack bye montage
goodbye Michael I might just be saying
things over and over by the way goodbye
Jacob Oh goodbye
[Music]
Yussef goodbye problem bear
goodbye Who am I goodbye moe goodbye
disturbia goodbye Jamie if you still
around I'm guessing you are
goodbye Tad's if you're still around I'm
guessing well yeah that's Jamie
bye bye and thank you also to everyone
who stuck around during the development
of this and kept me sane because so many
times I just second-guessing myself on
whether this game was even good like or
even remotely good you know I mean so
yeah thank you so so much can't thank
you enough
yeah goodbye for me anyway I mean you're
gonna carry on listening I'll put some
songs on okay
[Music]
I was just a child when I saw you there
you taught me how to fight sections that
just don't care through your lens
I saw beauty and hidden I kiddin
happenstance
three
[Music]
yes ha
since I'm upstairs
where Tom's arrayed in every shadow cast
and the evil eyes behind this lead every
day
[Music]
[Music]
my hope is network we will fight for
freedom of system 3 alongside such
diverse
[Music]
four kings
[Music]
this pirate ship
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]